so I did my list for the movies I'm most
excited about for next year but there's
another list and I haven't done this
before this is the movies that I'm
pretty certain are gonna suck now before
I get into this cuz I haven't done this
before so I want to clarify this because
I don't have precedent otherwise I am
NOT saying that I hope these movies suck
I hope they don't I hope that they are
good I don't because there's a pretty
good chance I'm going to go and see most
of these and I don't I don't ever go in
wanting to not like a movie I oftentimes
will go in expecting to not like a movie
I can't help that but I don't actively
want to and the other thing is this is a
little this is a short list this isn't a
top 10 and that is because I you know
I'm not a I'm not a professional critic
I don't have to see every movie that
comes out so there's all kinds of movies
that I can look at and go boy that's
gonna suck but I also don't care like
I'm pretty certain the sequel to Mamma
Mia is gonna suck but I also don't have
a dog in that race it doesn't matter to
me
if that movie sucks it makes absolutely
no difference so it's not it doesn't
something like that doesn't have a place
on this list all I have on here are
movies that I'm pretty sure gotta suck
and it matters to me that they're
probably gonna suck so that all being
established number seven solo a Star
Wars story I've got the reasons that I
think it's not gonna be good and then
I've got extra baggage just layered on
top of that and I'll try and keep it
short so I just think it's a bad idea a
han Solo movie you know earlier in his
career I just I don't understand the
appeal I don't understand why anyone
thinks we want that and the only reason
I was prepared to give it benefit of the
doubt earlier on was I have a lot of
faith in Lord Miller as directors but
they're not doing it so and that's not
to say that's not me saying they would
have remember Liam what they made might
have sucked too but at the very least
their approach is so unique that I was
more curious to see it now not so much
and when I said there's extra baggage it
is that without dredging up a whole
conversation about Star Wars the last
Jedi again most of the problems that I
have with that movie I feel are
structural either within the film itself
or within its place in the Star Wars
franchise as a whole which means they
were problems that existed at the script
stage and in my mind should have been in
some way addressed before it ever got
shot
so the reason that's a concern for me is
basically the reason Lord and Miller got
fired off this movie is because Kathleen
Kennedy loved the script so much she
basically fired them for not sticking to
it so if I go into this movie and if
it's not good which I'm pretty sure it
won't be but specifically if it's not
good because of basic script issues as
opposed to just being uninteresting
Direction bad performances etc if I look
at and go what are the problems with
this with this story and go boy the
script is bad that's really gonna sour
my hope for Star Wars as a whole because
that to me says Kathleen Kennedy doesn't
recognize quality writing yet she is
firing directors off movies because they
don't stick to a script that she is
deemed to be quality so if this script
sucks and and I feel like I will be able
to judge that because Ron Howard say
what you will about him he's not a guy
who does massive changes to a script he
kind of just shoots what he's given so
yeah I've got a lot of baggage tied up
in this one number 6 death wish this
might seem like an odd one for me to
bring up but how do I put this as
briefly as I can because I don't know I
don't know how well-known the original
Death Wish actually is but having seen
the trailer for death wish it seems to
be the antithesis of the actual hook of
that movie yes the original death wish
is a revenge story and so does this new
one with Bruce Willis appear to be but
the reason it's called death wish is
it's not a case of him going out and
hunting down the punks who hurt his
family what he does is he goes out and
deliberately goes into bad neighborhoods
at night and puts himself into dangerous
situations so that when people then
accost him and you know try and rob him
assault him whatever then after they
come after him only then does he enact
vengeance and kill people he's not
actively trying to get close
sure he actually has a death wish he's
putting himself in dangerous situations
where he might die and he's perfectly
okay doing that and I see this trailer
with Bruce Willis just hunting down
these people who heard his daughter I'm
like this is this is the latest take
this latest version of taken and if they
called it anything other than death wish
I wouldn't care but calling a death wish
just pisses me off
number five fantastic beasts the crimes
of Grindelwald again I don't want this
to suck but I've got a lot of reasons
that I'm pretty sure will and no it's
not all because of Johnny Depp although
at this point he doesn't help he's not a
check in the positive column for me
anymore um and that's regardless of what
you feel about him about what's been
going on with him off screen I'm just
kind of done with the guy so I just I am
not especially interested in this angle
I don't like how dark things got right
off the bat I want a director other than
David Yates to start to Shepherd this
property again a big part of what was
interesting about the Harry Potter
franchise was that it had such a
different field from film to film and
you know the the films David Gates
directed in that series were fine but I
really disliked that they gave the new
spin-off to the guy who made the most of
the main trilogy like they're not
trilogy it's eight films otology and I
don't I don't like that it's we're just
now bogged down in his specific way of
interpreting this world because it's not
the most interesting version I don't
think and I also don't know how much
faith I have in JK Rowling at this point
cuz I've read the curse child and yeah
so I I I don't know man I'd they're just
I would like it to be good but there's
very little battle where I can go to and
go maybe that's the saving grace I just
see a whole series of red flags
number four Jurassic Park the fallen
Kingdom boy this looks dumb and yes in
regards to the video I made on the
initial trailer it has been confirmed
that pretty much everything in that
first trailer is only from the first act
of the movie so the stuff that we saw in
that initial trailer is not
whole plot of the movie that doesn't
save anything for me because it still
looks really dumb and even if that's
only the first half hour forty minutes
and then it goes somewhere else after
that that's still gonna be the movie
digging a hole of dumb and if it gets
better after that it's it's still not
gonna be great because it's gotta get
out of this hole that it's dug of the
exact same let's find a really contrived
reason to put people we already know on
an island of dinosaurs again only this
time there's also a volcano it's dumb
and into a point that it doesn't matter
to me what you do after that cuz you've
lost me already
number three How the Grinch Stole
Christmas I've never talked about the
live-action Jim Carrey How the Grinch
Stole Christmas and I probably never
will because it'll just be me screaming
for probably about an hour this will
probably not be that bad but it is just
as unnecessary and it's very clear from
the few little snippets we've gotten
visually that it is trying to look like
the Chuck Jones special which makes it
all the more pointless because that's
special as far as I'm concerned is
perfect to try and tell that story in
feature-length you have to add something
you have to add padding and maybe it
won't be the same kind of painful that
the live-action version was but look at
the padding that's been added to dr.
Seuss stories that have even when
they've been done animated the padding
that was added to the Lorax the padding
that was added to horton hears a who
which is probably the best one that was
done but the padding was still painful
even that original short was padded but
it was padded in a smart way with
musical numbers as opposed to actually
trying to add new plot elements whatever
it is they have to do to cram into this
to stretch it out to a feature length is
going to render it pointless and stupid
and inferior we have the perfect version
stop number two Hotel Transylvania 3
summer vacation the Hotel Transylvania
franchise I don't hate it it's okay
mostly I'm frustrated that it's what get
eternity off ski is spending a
I'm doing cuz he's a really great
animation director and I love his stuff
and honestly the visual styling and
energy and mood and speed and pace of
these movies is by far their best aspect
and I just hate that this is what he's
spending his time and his energy doing
and in addition to that like let's just
take the characters and put them on a
cruise like how what a contrived
scenario it just it just reeks of Shrek
the third it reeks it reeks of Little
Fockers you know that there was a little
bit of mileage in in the Hotel
Transylvania 2 not a lot but there was a
little there were places to go at this
point is like let's just put him on a
boat now no no please just stop and my
number one movie of 2018 that I am
pretty certain is gonna suck I'm not
gonna spend a whole ton of time on
because I have a whole video dedicated
about wiping is gonna suck its x-men
Dark Phoenix
so condensed version the people behind
the x-men franchise don't seem to
understand what it is that actually
makes that story work we have to already
care about not only the team as a whole
we have to care about Jean Grey
specifically this only did a second
movie we've gotten this version of Jean
Grey played by sophie turner she did
almost nothing in Apocalypse aside from
the fact that Apocalypse was
aggressively mediocre I think most
people have chosen to forget the movie
as a whole and they brought back a ton
of actors who they think are the big
marquee names Michael Fassbender and
James McAvoy and Jennifer Lawrence and
are shoving them in here when two out of
three of them have no place in this
story and to put them in there and
knowing just that there they are the
most expensive actors and the people
producing this think they are part of
the reason that the franchise is
successful they are gonna get a whole
ton of screen time which means it's
gonna be less time devoted to Jean les
I'm devoted to Scott les I'm devoted to
the people that have to work for this
story to matter everything indicates
that this is gonna be a raging mess of a
movie and it doesn't help that is the
directorial debut of a producer who has
never directed anything
his life before no hope on this one you
want further details on this out link in
my original video at the end of this so
those are my thoughts on the movies that
I'm pretty certain are gonna suck next
year what are the ones that you are
pretty certain will not be any good but
that you might go see anyways because
most of the movies on this list I'm
probably gonna see anyways what are they
for you whatever they are drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
don't forget to like subscribe check me
out on Twitter at Council of geeks
Council of geeks podcast is on Apple
podcast and stitcher radio I'm also one
happen to punch like a girl podcast
that's a presentation of the fire and
water podcast network Fire Water podcast
comm links for all this stuff is down in
the description and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]